steve bannon was talking to charlie kirk
and he said 35 trump allies had been
raided by the fbi
and that's a shocking claim and then
harmeet dillon a lawyer well-respected
you know came out and said can confirm
it happen to people i know as well and
so
it's it seems very much concern
confirmed i mean i'll tell you this
steve bannon was perp walked
after he turned himself into custody
we didn't see that for the blm leaders
who are who are effectively accused of
the exact same you know potential crimes
but they they're putting on a show for
everybody and uh hearing that 35 trump
allies have been raided is um
yo it's getting pretty pretty crazy out
there we got a bunch of stories man
crime is playing a big role in the
upcoming election democrats and
vulnerable districts are starting to
realize this and we got we got a story
out of california i want to talk because
i want to talk about crime a woman was
beheaded in the street
in front of a bunch of people
and i don't want to just play into like
anecdotes because i know sometimes crime
happens but this is part of a larger
trend of a massive uptick in crime that
we need to talk about especially when it
comes to policing policies and how that
stuff plays out self-defense and how
there's this move by these woke
politicians to decriminalize and allow
violent offenders out while basically
arresting small business owners so we'll
talk about all that stuff plus uh aoc
she's getting criticized because she
said she didn't know if interracial
marriage was right for her it's very
interesting to hear a progressive person
because the progressives are the ones
who are saying that if you had a racial
dating preference you were racist but
before we get started my friends head
over to surfinginternetsafe.com
to get virtual shield a virtual private
network you know on this page they
mentioned 80 000 plus ir our irs agents
prove government has proof government
has no limits yeah they're going to be
going after regular people so the point
of this
virtual shield is a virtual private
network service it provides you with a
basic layer of security so when you
browse the web
governments hackers just nefarious
actors can't steal your data or at least
it makes it more difficult to do so so
again surfing internetsafe.com
virtual shield lets you browse the web
completely anonymously big name isps and
other third parties will not be able to
monitor and sell your internet activity
you'll get a fast reliable secure and
always available network that is
completely free for 30 days and
available on mac windows iphone ipad
android or chrome virtual shield does
all the work you download you press go
you're good to go
they route your internet through their
advanced encrypted servers across the
globe to prevent isps from being able to
track your internet traffic and blocking
your browsing abilities maybe there's a
government block in some country that's
stopping you from viewing a perfectly
legal website or something like that
maybe you want to be able to watch it
they got personal family and business
plans available family plans got 15
devices business plans elected as many
as you want and it will also encrypt
your wi-fi connection so shout out to
virtual shield for sponsoring the show
head over to surfing internet safe we
really do appreciate it and i'm gonna
give a shout out right now to tom
mcdonald tom mcdonald's got a new song
out and i'm gonna be promoting this all
next week because
i i genuinely mean it when we got a push
back in the culture war and we've got to
win in terms of uh producing culture
tom's got a new song out today called
riot this is when billboard reporting
starts it ends next thursday
everybody needs to check out the song we
put the link in the description below
you can buy it we put the amazon link
it's easier but if you go to his song
he's number four on trending it's not an
overtly political song it's just good
stuff by somebody who's got a good
message behind the work that he does i'm
a big fan of tom i want to see him hit
billboard number one on the hot 100
maybe we can't pull it off but we need
to organize and so what i'm saying is
when you have somebody like tom who's
successful got a big following and is
getting
basically blocked whenever he has a
successful song from the chart from
charts and from the media if we organize
we can make it undeniable so everybody
buy his song let's get him a number one
on itunes that's gonna be number one on
billboard i'll tell you this right now
i am so i i i am gonna
if tom mcdonald hits
number one where should wh what should
which what should the stakes be yeah
yeah
man number one on billboard yeah number
one on billboard i'll wear a suit
[Laughter]
yeah somebody chatted that you're gonna
look good they said so if tom mcdonald
hits number one on uh on
on billboard high 100 number one is
really tough to get so i'm kind of like
you know i'm kind of a suit and a tie a
suit and a tie all right if
so if everybody who listens to the show
buys tom mcdonald's riot either on
itunes or amazon
i think you would need like 100k sales
not only does that give tom more money
to do his work
but it would force the media to
acknowledge counter culture and
anti-establishment and then i'll put a
suit on
that would be a huge win i feel like you
got to up the stakes a suit a dress tim
will wear a dress
if you make this number one come on
let's get these people working a pink
scantily
we all wear suits i don't have a suit
but i will get you i'll definitely wear
one so
what about you lydia
i mean i guess and we'll get luca's suit
too but you got to send like a camera
crew to the fitting i want to see ian
get it
and we'll get really nice tailored suits
that'd be a cool like social psychology
experiment to see how much it changes
the show like if you guys are just more
like uh formal yeah
you into character for sure being in
costume so anyway um look i've been
talking about we we released a song the
media told us to f off said they
wouldn't cover the fact that we hit
number two on digital sales because they
don't like me and so my my whole thing
is
let's force them to acknowledge the
counterculture give them no opportunity
it's 99 cents it supports tom we don't
get any of that money it goes to him so
he can keep doing the work he does i'm a
big fan of his seeing him hit the top of
the charts and then forcing the media to
write about a guy who wrote a song
called fake woke in the system and rags
on on on on the cult i i would just oh
man it would be shot in frodo knowing
they would just be so angry and having
around mcdonald's number one
i'd love to see it and i'll wear suit i
will so uh shout out tom right now
he's currently number three on itunes so
you can see so uh i'm i'm really excited
for this and i'm also pointing this out
too because his latest song isn't
overtly political he does rag on
mainstream music and the machine but
it's not overtly political that's the
point we need to produce culture that
inspires young people yeah and invades
these spaces and forces them to
acknowledge it so we'll we'll uh
check out a song buy it make it happen
get number one we put suits on also
don't forget you can become a member at
timcast.com support our work directly if
you'd like to check out the cass castle
vlog the latest episode with ian as the
the main star running for union
president
and then at this point now spoilers i
think are okay let's just say ian's
running for union president and you know
when when they're when they're counting
the votes for uh to see who won well we
said the early ballots came at 3am and
you you know how it goes so you guys
definitely want to check that one out
joining us because you've already heard
them speak already we've got we've got
some awesome guests we've got maje toure
what's up who are you dude
it's a regular dude man north
philadelphia i'm saying philadelphian
founder of black guns matter founder of
the solutionary lifestyle
you know
reform scumbag right now right now
all right we got dave smith what's going
on very good to be back it's uh it's
been a little while and it's great to
see all of you guys again and you guys
know me comedian podcaster takeover of
libertarian parties and it it's just you
know just a coincidence that you're both
here at the same time
just having to be in the area you know
we had you both on at the same time for
no reason coincidentally randomly uh
before the show we talked about what
everybody ate for breakfast but we also
talked about universal healthcare
colonial did we talk about colonialism
generational wealth the queen world
economic forum the history of pioneers 9
11 9 11 before the mike's even like what
was like hold on well i like to start
first because he wants to save it for
the show so let's get hot and heavy
right yeah it was great before the show
we kept trying to talk about like what
we had for breakfast so we kept going
back to like monsanto and stuff it was
not like that's the system we ate the
system for breakfast like exactly
let's get going it's hard to turn it off
yeah yeah it's like we're getting ready
with the cameras and then i you know
dave would be saying something i'd say
what'd you have for breakfast and then
within like five minutes it's like
monsanto man you know with these cokes
like here we go
you get eggs you thought you were eating
eggs bro
all right well let's jump into this
first story let's talk about some
authoritarianism yeah from tim cass
breaking steve bannon says at least 35
trump allies had their homes raided by
the fbi on thursday he was speaking with
charlie kirk harmeet dillon came out
said can confirm confirm this happened
to many trump allies i know as well so
i'm wondering if it's actually more than
35 the quote here is there were 35 raids
last night ben and said and there's
another grand jury coming together on
january 6 the washington post reported
35 senior members of maga republicans
supporters of donald trump that the fbi
role rolled in on so i'm wondering you
know biden comes out and he says maga
republicans are an extreme threat
a lot of us were like oh that's their
campaign strategy right i'm wondering
it's more than that
that they want to prime the american
people say it enough get enough of their
bots and garbage corporate press to
agree right that way when they start
arresting people they'll say oh but you
guys know how bad it is right
well it's hard it's hard to say for sure
right exactly what that was and and it
certainly you know could be okay this is
a campaign video and this is a the play
right the the play for the midterm
elections well he can't claim to be a
unifier or any of this stuff anymore he
can't really run on any of his policies
so basically what's his only play left
is to gin up his own base by saying hey
the other side is so evil to get out the
votes for for democrats um kind of a
desperate attempt but i gotta say and
this is what i was talking about the
other day when when that speech was
given on my podcast part of the problem
uh that i was saying look this really
reminded me
of like a george w bush 2002 speech
it had everything from like i mean the
creepy red backdrop the military members
like right behind him this was like it
seemed like a war drum
speech like if you remember you know 9
11 happened in september 2001 we invade
iraq in 2003 but the whole year of 2002
was this slow you know beating the war
drums pushing the war propaganda about
what saddam hussein is doing and it did
have that feel to it i think that look
let's just call it what it is donald
trump for
four years
was framed for treason by his own deep
state by his own intelligence uh
apparatus now that is kind of
a real
thing that that's something pretty
interesting that you have the cia and
the fbi and the nsa working to oust a
democratically elected president with
help from the corporate press oh yes
with help from the corporate press from
uh from social media from big tech from
the you know pretty both uh both parties
as well so now what you're really seeing
is that it has definitely been deemed
unacceptable to the establishment for
donald trump to be re-elected i mean not
re-elected elected again whatever you
want to call it
think about that what a devastating blow
that would be for their narrative and i
think that after the fbi raid in
mar-a-lago
they went big
there's no i don't think they can do
that and not follow this up with
something big they can't just raid a
former president's house and then say
all right we didn't find anything it's
nothing they gotta go for it now so this
is you know again if bannon is is
telling the truth and this is what
happened this is another major
escalation in that step bannon's not the
kind of guy to to hoax like this no and
and harmeet dylan's a lawyer she's not
this hyper-partisan i mean she's
obviously you know partisan in a certain
sense but
she's a lawyer coming out saying can
confirm this happened i i take it
seriously the the the thing i think that
we the general public should actually
look when they see this
okay cool you don't like trump you love
trump whatever thing you fall in in that
space i think the thing that the general
public should really be thinking about
is
these are the
weaponization of entire intelligence
communities to go after presidents and
to slow somebody up for their okay i'm
gonna go in again in o4 right so if
they're doing that to someone and that's
their political opposition that has
resources that has
access that has all these other
different things the general public
should be thinking more so about do you
want to vote for a guy come in a few
years do you want to vote for a party do
you want to vote for a system or group
that has consistently shown you because
it's not just on the left they're just
the guys in charge the democrats now and
they're unhinged with it like that whole
mar-a-lago thing adrian norman really he
posted on his twitter page it's like
here right here it's saying this was
sent by biden
yeah clarence claren you know whatever
so this is
just to clarify this one's interesting
biden and may requested what the
documents they thought trump had were
yeah then they go and raid trump's mar a
lot like mar-a-lago with the feds you
know a few months later and so it's did
biden literally say i want you to raid
his house or did he go oh won't someone
please get me these documents and then
wink wink nudge nudge the feds went and
did it i think is
again like we were saying before camera
i'm past the point of believing that
this is incompetence agreed um it's too
it's too strategic you know the sun
rises and and if you're depending on
your location the sun's right there
every at this time the sun's going to be
here that is an organized phenomenon
it's too many oopsies in yeah because
we're looking at
biden as this
you know the old dude that's struggling
with dementia and we kind of like that
might be the drunken monkey like i'm not
above this is a very intricate movie we
made this joke before that biden
bumbles and fumbles off stage and then
as soon as he's behind the curtain he
stands up the evil and he goes all right
did they buy it now let's go blow up
some kids in the middle east right well
i but i also think like whether it how
much of it went up to joe biden and how
aware he was it's almost irrelevant at a
certain point i mean we know it went to
merrick garland right so it's he already
said in his own press conference that
this was his decision so it went to very
high places i don't know if that's
at that point who really cares whether
it was the president or just his
attorney general right now like
i think what's important too to
recognize with this is that it's not
even like really a left verse right
thing this is a power verse non-power
thing this is an establishment
anti-establishment thing i mean think
about the way the uh someone i disagree
with on a ton of things but think about
the way the establishment turned against
bernie sanders you know in in 2016
really rigging the entire election
against him in the democratic primary
think about the way in 2020 when he was
looking very good against joe biden they
were on msnbc and cnn calling his
supporters brown shirts and nazis what
do you think the system would do if
bernie sanders had been elected
president so
people clarify that they they mounted a
procedural effort against bernie sanders
like questions were being given to
hillary clinton in advance by cnn in
2020 they had the three moderates drop
out and all endorse joe biden at the
same time so it's this it's this bad
elizabeth stay in right they had her
stay in so the one who is splitting
votes from him stays in all the ones who
are splitting votes from joe biden get
out and endorse biden so it's it's it's
this like
they they they flex and bend the system
so everything always skews in their
favor in those ways and what happened
and they did that with trump too but it
didn't work for once it didn't work and
that guy got in and so it's just the the
thing that should be eye-opening to
regular people is that you go look if
ever you supported a candidate from the
left-wing perspective who deviated from
the establishment too much they would
crack down on him in the same way and
the thing that the trump supporters
should be questioning about how how much
loyalty you have to donald trump going
forward is just like
donald trump appointed rey to the head
of the fbi he is the guy you know if his
mission his stated mission was to drain
the swamp well man he got drained by
that swamp he hired bolton right like
everybody went dude bolton pompeo bar
you know ray all of these guys his
entire team oh so he had no clue who to
trust and who not to trust and he got
rolled by although
he kept foundry on the job all of 2020.
is that i cannot believe that that's
incompetence i i i do not believe that
that's incompetence and again
my job is to look at the general
republicans saying hey
this doesn't this looks fishy and if you
see it from the left or the right or
whatever if this looks fishy is this
where you want to put your energy
locally state or federally do you want
to get behind those types of things
again because it's walking like a duck
bro it been walking like a duck looking
like a duck for however long but this is
what's this is what we're seeing right
now
if the 35 raids on trump allies we're
watching a revolution happen we are we
are watching a political faction
with control of law enforcement
using it to crush political opposition
historically when you see things like
this happen it's typically how you end
up with a uniparty system now i think
for the most part there are democrats
and republicans for a long time have
been the youth party as it was with this
fake you know this this false
adversary right right right but
donald trump storms the gates trump
supporters bernie sanders supporters
tried storming the gates too bernie was
too nice of a guy i guess he was too
weak he couldn't he couldn't he couldn't
get in that ivory tower bernie sanders
walks up to the ivory tower with a bunch
of these lefties shake their fist they
say let us sin let us in and they they
spit on him and then he apologizes
donald trump they came with a battering
ram
then they bring in the big orange bull
who just rampages about they want to
regain control of the establishment this
is how they're trying to do it by
purging and arresting all of their
opposition
let me tell you real quick just how
scary it gets
they're going after trump supporters
they're going to trump people they're
not going after republicans the
republicans are going to be the
establishment but i'll tell you what
happened when i was when i was in egypt
when they had the second revolution
they realized that the the political
split between the more secular type
egyptians and the muslim brotherhood was
too great and there was only one
solution and you know they did
you know what the military decided to do
to stop the the the constant revolution
that a revolution the revolution again
they just went and started killing the
muslim brotherhood they just went out
started arresting started firing guns at
and just attacking their their their
their protests
now it's not that bad they're not going
out and just killing trump supporters
but it's because we're in a different
degree of warfare that's third third
third generation now we're in fifth
they're using the power of law
enforcement to make sure trump's people
can't assist him and that his ideas and
his leadership are gone yeah well that's
it's interesting when you say we're in a
revolution and you could really think
about in the history of the united
states of america like we have kind of
this idea that we've had one regime
since 1776 but really there's been many
revolutions along the way i mean we had
a revolution where we overthrew the
articles of confederation and installed
the constitution um we certainly had a
revolution with abraham lincoln where we
fought a civil war uh i think you could
argue that uh fdr kind of was a
revolution well my point would be here
the revolution was 2020. the revolution
isn't 2022. the revolution was having
the lockdown regime having what
bordered on a color-coded revolution
with these kind of like very um
let's say sponsored mass rioting and
protesting in the streets i mean this is
right out of the playbook of what we do
in other countries so this is the
follow-up to that the 529 insurrection
when they went to the white house ripped
down the barricades injured dozens of
federal agents set fire to a guard post
set fire to a church and forced the
president into a bunker yeah and no one
talks about that right it's very
interesting right but so this is this is
the follow-up to that like if this big
push was made you could look at that
time magazine piece about how they stole
the election from donald trump if this
big push was made to to get trump out
and put joe biden in well this is now
the follow-up to that now how do you
this is usually after a revolution you
have this period where then you have to
crack down on the dissidents to make
sure that the the power that you took is
now this change
it's all part of the revolutionary
process you mentioned the civil war
a civil war happens when factions fight
each other and neither side can just
take it right what we're watching now is
i don't know i don't care if it's
democrats it is the elite and they're
using and mostly as democrats and
there's some you know former republican
neocon types but they
what we're seeing is still the
revolutionary period so if in november
republicans win
then the revolution is not complete if
in 2024 trump wins then the revolution
then the revolution failed
right to some degree but sitting here
watching i i i
i can't believe that we have a story
that 35 trump senior trump people were
were raided by feds like that is such a
dramatic escalation i think they're
doing what's going to come out of this
is this is the streisand effect they're
doing something they're thinking about
we got to keep trump out they're not
thinking about the general public
watching going you guys are shitty
they're doing a lot of the heavy lifting
for us and i don't mean that in a good
way like oh great yeah raid more you
know mag extremist so-called and then
the people will wake up but that's kind
of like in a weird way what's happening
the general public how many times are
y'all are y'all hearing guys that may
have voted for biden
and they fought you tooth and nail in 20
whatever right 19. yeah this is blah
blah blah blah blah now after a year and
a half two years they're like bro i i
don't know i don't really they may not
be willing to say yeah i'm going this
way completely but they're also going
like nah something's wrong here i don't
even like how this feels economically
they're doing something this massive
over correction
that the general public is i think for
me
i don't think that anybody's just going
yeah we're going biden and i don't think
that they're going we're raiding these
people and people aren't seeing i think
it would work if it was more clandestine
i want to jump to this story here
and it's brutal
man arrested after beheading young
mother in the middle of san carlos
street law enforcement sources
now they they may have had a domestic
issue the guy attacks her and then uses
a sword to remove her head in in view
the public and there's two things i
notice from this
you know there's a story uh i think it
was a few months ago maybe a year ago
about a woman who was on a subway train
when a man raped her it was in philly
and everybody watched and they filmed it
and just let it happen and i thought to
myself like how does that happen that
people just stand there and watch that
like watch someone do that
same thing here now i get it with this
story dude as a sword right okay guys
got a sword
what can you really do shoot him but yes
that was the correct answer not in
california
not in california where they
criminalized self-defense is that what
that happened was in cali yeah so here's
here's my point right we're segueing off
of this you know what's happening with
this revolution and you made a really
good point before the show dave you said
that they're decriminalizing like
they're letting people go with all this
violent crime and then they're
criminalizing self-defense right that is
an untenable situation for any
civilization and the only result can be
collapsed well you know something really
interesting about like the kind of rise
of the progressive prosecutors who i you
know from my perspective a lot of times
as they were uh running in some places
where they need to get elected or as
they were like campaigning for the job
they they made points that i thought
were somewhat reasonable when they were
talking about you know things like bail
reform where you look you you certainly
can make the argument that it's a pretty
messed up system
that if you have money
you get out of jail and if you don't
have the money you have to stay in jail
until trial there's there's an ar
there's a really reasonable argument to
have there there's certainly a
reasonable argument that over the last
40 years in america we have been way too
harsh on crimes like uh like drug
possession even drug distribution on
crimes like gun possession you know
these things it's it's outrageous the
amount of people's lives who we've
ruined for for these non-violent
victimless crimes
so the the progressive prosecutors kind
of used that popular energy to rise up
and then they went okay but not only are
we going to do that yeah we're also
going to go really easy on violent
criminals we're also going to
decriminalize not just shoplifting but
strong armed robbery carjacking and all
of this because we don't want to throw
throw away the book for anyone except
when someone's uh exercising
self-defense then they become reaganite
drug warrior prosecutors who want to
throw the book at you who want to like
throw you know 30 years in jail for so
it creates control
yes it creates this thing that is
obviously just going to destroy
civilization you can't have a society
where you legalize property crimes and
violent crimes asset de facto legalize
them and and then punish people for
defending themselves they are they are
punishing the good the let me live my
life happily and leave me alone and
exonerating allowing commuting
protecting the bad quite literally it's
like
letting the demons loose
and
it's it's an inversion of what the
system is and what's protecting you and
my only point there is that basically
that like the um the conservative
prosecutors gave them this lane from 40
years of insane aggressive prosecutions
of people for like drug possession
charges so then they could run against
that and then be like isn't that so
horrible and then they give us this
insanity what we need is libertarian
prosecutors basically is that yes let's
not throw people in jail for drug
possession or gun possession but also if
you defend your life or your property
then we should always come down on the
side of that person and against the
criminal it should be like this i'm
imagining there's like a d.a
and uh there's like a courtroom and some
guy mugged some other guy and so here
they both are one dudes on trial for the
crime one dude's you know the victim and
then the judge is just like
okay so you know we've heard all the
evidence it really does sound like you
mugged this guy then he looks over the
victim and says do you have a gun and he
goes uh no i don't it was okay so
restitution will be we're going to give
you a gun it's cheaper to give you a gun
than put this guy in jail we're going to
tell this guy
don't commit crimes because the next
time dude's going to be armed and so
will everyone else i'm kidding by the
way but the idea is like
if people were armed good good
law-abiding citizens who are armed not
in west virginia i've never had a
problem with them i see i saw a guy
walking on the street with a crossbow
once and i'm like how's it going do you
support uh prosecuting violent crime oh
yeah of course what about
people that command people to do
violence
so i'm sorry so oh so well someone
re-ordered this priest things like that
and then someone goes oh that one's done
yeah this is why people who command
other people to do violence ought to be
prosecuted too that's why george w bush
and barack obama should all be in a cell
somewhere for the uh the wars that they
got hey did you guys know that obama and
trump two and biden too
because it's like i want to pardon all
it's like what you mean obama murdered a
kid oh yeah several yeah several but no
nobody like an american an american
citizen
son
right but but we don't even need to say
that we can just say did you know that
barack obama murdered a kid yeah like
murdered an american kid people are
going to be like what like
it wasn't murder because it was legal no
no it wasn't literally trying to let
some bomb in it no he wants no it not
even that it was a civilian restaurant
in a country we weren't at war with
he blew up civilians an american citizen
and we weren't at war with yemen it was
the definition of like
it wasn't even a war crime because we're
not at war it was just literally obama
murdering somebody yeah but and by the
way that's when obama was uh uh drone
bombing yemen up to 2009 2010 when we
were on uh the site we were drone
bombing to supposedly kill al qaeda but
then he switched and okay we continued
the bombing campaign to this day on the
side of al qaeda because now we're
against the houthis because we had to
kind of win over favor with the saudis
again so we kept that war going this
entire time and switched sides and we
are still to this day currently fighting
on the side of al qaeda so mix war
crimes with treason with genocide
yeah and that's what you've got in yemen
right now like donald trump was like why
do we have troops over there and donald
trump was trying to get our troops out
donald trump was lied to by uh uh who i
can't remember who lied to him about
syria told them that we yeah they
bragged about it they were worried about
that we they forced to keep our troops
in we had the abraham accords we had
trump uh negotiating with north korea we
had trump basically being like i don't
know how we're involved in this stuff
this is costing us money for no reason
but yeah but no excuses for him man
because
he first of all he wrote up like first
off he got tricked into surging in
afghanistan before he finally agreed to
end it and then he agrees to end it on a
timeline that will be on the next guy's
administration i i guess he assumed he
was getting re-elected but while he took
that risk
by the way he had colonel douglas
mcgregor come in to the defense
department in the lame duck session
after he lost the election but before he
was out and he uh he rode up the order
to remove all troops from syria and
afghanistan and trump signed it and then
the next day trump took it back because
someone got in the room with them and
convinced him not to do it and he did
this over and over and over again so
fine it is true that they all misled him
and lied to him but like no excuses for
the commander-in-chief and president he
had four years in there of being the
commander-in-chief the genocide in yemen
continued every single day of his
administration by the way uh
1-833-stopwar.com go there there's a war
powers resolution coming up this is the
big project of the libertarian party
right now to try to get you to go call
your congressman there's a bill in the
congress uh in the house and the senate
to try to bring an end to this general i
got it i got to push back a little bit
just because
i think in terms of war trump was the
best president of my lifetime why
because he was getting our troops out he
didn't start any new ones he okay he
didn't start any new ones he definitely
uh
gave it his who gave it his best try
when he uh murdered solomoni and could
have gotten us into the worst war in the
last 20 years i didn't say it was thank
god i didn't say that was good i who was
better
every other president in my life started
several wars
and so i understand like bro okay but it
started listen i like that talking point
i like that the talking point is he
didn't start a new war rather than it
being like he was so great because he
was so aggressive you know like he was
such a war hawk like it would have been
with previous republicans but i mean
okay he didn't start any new wars that
is technically true again he flirted
around and flirted in uh venezuela but
you know
the the number of civilian casualties
actually went up in his uh you know he
didn't end any of the wars he continued
all of them uh well he okay i give him
all the credit in the world he authored
the deal that ultimately ended the war
in afghanistan and by the way even
though he botched the execution i gave
biden credit too for ending that fine
but donald trump was the
commander-in-chief for four years on the
promise that he was going to end these
wars no excuse making for that kept them
all going for all four years
i think the difference in our
perspectives is because i agree with you
but my thing is like i have to
be positive on people who are making
progress
so that we can continue to encourage the
the election of people who will follow
further and further in that direction of
but then i'll say if we want to make
progress but he didn't really make
progress and is what i'm saying if more
people are being killed of course if
more if
what is that so that's a p what deal
what piece did he strike with who so
when you have planes that are traveling
over israel right when you have
countries like what is it saudi arabia
among other arabic nations that are now
allowing an inter-country commerce it's
just a step in the right direction no
there was no war between saudi arabia
and israel there was no war between the
u.s
and israel if you had the passport so
basically what he did was in these in
these peace deals is he basically bought
off these other muslim countries to be
friends with israel when they had vowed
well when they had vowed to not be
friends with israel over their treatment
of the palestinian people and so we
bribed them with u.s taxpayer dollars to
look the other way and let israel do
what they want to do to the palestinian
people in order to not like be enemies
with them so if that's a peace deal fine
but if i'm talking about the actual wars
the war in in yemen the war in uh in
somalia the wars in all of these
countries like no he didn't end them so
that's the type of peace deal i'd be
looking for so i agree with you i want
to see progress but i think the way to
get progress is to say like no that's
not good enough we're actually expecting
when we when you run on saying we're
going to end the wars that means end the
freaking wars like end them all this is
insane we're we're draining we're
bankrupting our country to be the empire
of the world and for what what do we
even get out of it what have we got okay
in the last 20 years in iraq afghanistan
libya syria somalia pakistan yemen like
all these campaigns what have we gotten
from petrodollar yeah opium and lithium
no no no no no no no no no no it's the
petrodone right it's that we don't have
to do anything to buy oil literally
nothing
the funny thing about that is that it's
like even that
how does that benefit the american
people i mean what it benefits it
benefits the federal reserve right like
they can print all the money they want
and there's still something that's kind
of backing up its currency but how is
that actually benefiting regular people
well i'll tell you so it allows their
government to rape them even more well
but but it does benefit the american
people i'm not a fan of how the system
works but it does so the gdp of say uh
brazil
has to be high so they can with uh
what's the what's the brazilian currency
man i can't come someone will hook it up
i believe it's the brazilian the
brazilian that's it that's exactly what
it is so uh what is it i should know the
answer okay so it's the mexican peso no
it's not the mexican peso in brazil are
you sure ian yes i'm pretty sure the
brazilian real rea yeah say hey i don't
know why mexican pesos
so uh in order to buy oil they got to
trade that for petro dollars they got it
for the dollar so you can buy on the
market with us what we do is
u.s currency is created upon the the
transaction of a loan so when you buy a
house the bank just manifests half a
million dollars for the house or
whatever it is you're buying and that
money appears the bank bank account of
the person who sold the house it was not
nothing was done to make that happen in
brazil you've got to actually sell stuff
you've got to actually make stuff you've
got to trade stuff and you've got to do
it internationally your gdp has to be
higher your exports have to be higher
than your imports so that means people
have to be making things and selling
them overseas where in the united states
the american people can literally do
nothing and the u.s government can
acquire oil that we use for machinery
for production for food subsidies it
does benefit the industry no so all of
that's right but it's like which of the
american people is it benefiting really
and because what i'm seeing throughout
this entire process is the entire
working class in the american of america
being hollowed out right and so yes it's
benefiting the people what it allows is
like it benefits the speculators trading
in the wall street casino and it
benefits the people who work for weapons
companies or the think tanks that are
funded by those weapons companies who go
and lobby for the next war but i'm
telling you that i think overall it's a
net negative for that for the average
american what it is is the lifeblood
it's the lifeblood of the empire but the
empire is the enemy of the republic it's
the enemy of the people i agree
i prefer a system where people work
trade and
you you have what you make you use your
hands you use your mind you make you
create you live a good life you share
with your neighbors your neighbors come
together you build something great and
that should be from within our borders
and we can do international trade when
other countries agree to trade with us i
don't like the system of the reserve
there's an argument that's made often
about if we don't do it you know china
will fill the power vacuum and there's
questions about a unipolar chinese world
and things like that i should say
chinese communist world my thing is i
don't think any of the wars have ever
been justified they've made ridiculous
justifications for them but if you
actually look at what the goal of these
wars were if you look at the goal of why
they're giving money away it's simple
why did syria happen
let's just say i'm i agree with you i'm
i'm done believing this stuff is an
accident
the united states said they
okay so we go back to the you're
familiar with the cutter turkey pipeline
deal all that stuff the us wanted to
build a build a pipeline with our allies
from iraq syria turkey into europe
offset russia's monopoly syria said no
we're allies with russia conveniently
somehow a civil war erupted in syria and
then we were just on the side against
the dude who blocked our natural gas
pipeline
so that would have up upset gazprom lo
and behold the conflict in ukraine it's
all part of the same thing russia now is
strangling out with prices you know
energy prices in europe the whole
purpose of what we what we've done
internationally is effectively a hostage
situation so that everyone has to use
the dollar to buy oil with and the
reason we give money out when you're
like why are we giving 12 million
dollars to gender studies in pakistan
during a pandemic when we're shut down
our economy is collapsing because if you
give them the money they will use it and
so long as they use it confidence
remains in the in the currency which we
use
so we can buy oil and not have to do
work it is a hostage situation across
the board i'm not a fan of it i don't i
don't i don't think it's good i don't
think any of it's justified so this is
what they don't tell the regular people
but at a certain point
long term
again
empires doing empire [ __ ] is one thing
constitutional republics respecting the
citizens and not trying to just go
murder people to justify for that dollar
i think you both have excellent points
you're saying this is why we completely
agree right oh yeah no no we're
basically on the same page i'm just
saying that the entire what this has led
to the entire consumer economy rather
than kind of like the economy of because
basically it went from gold standard to
petro standard like that was basic i
mean there's a few years in between but
it was all it was early 70s to mid 70s
when we went from the petrodollar
when we went from the gold standard to
the the petrodollar and what happens
then as you enter into this this age of
like wild inflation and by the way
inflation's been happening all the way
throughout just depending on how you
measure it you know it's like they they
use the cpi to measure inflation but if
you really sit back and think about it
what were the price of things in the 70s
right versus the price of things now
everything is drastically more expensive
go go talk to like your parents about
who anyone who like bought a home yeah
what they bought a home for you
yeah yeah right
inflation has been with us this whole
time and it's it's shown in lots of
different ways but this economy i think
has done much more damage that then it
has benefited regular american people
what it's done is kind of put out of uh
it's put the basic things that most
people want out of reach the idea that
like hey we could have let's say one job
in this family and that could support
the entire family oh with that one job
we could own a house and send our kids
to college and have health insurance and
have all of the basic things that most
regular people want now they're with the
husband and wife working it's still
completely out of reach so i don't buy
into this narrative that like we're
benefiting i i've always said empire is
more of a cost than it is a benefit but
there's a lot of complicated uh
nuances around the get out of here fly
are you working for the empire yeah yeah
that moth has been harassed
so a lot of people say stuff like you
know 70 years ago a high school
education was enough to raise a family
of to support a family of five and it's
like what did you need to own
you you didn't need to own things right
today you have to have a computer you
have to have a phone and and and it's
because
let's say you go work at any job let's
say you want to be a pizza delivery boy
you better have a cell phone right okay
well phones have gotten a lot cheaper
but you you you require certain
materials now that people didn't require
before it's like you could go to get a
job
working somewhere and it's like phones
were there as part of the company so
the phone isn't really what's putting
people but isn't what make is what's
making people bankrupt right i mean
those kids can afford a phone i'm saying
there's a lot of different factors that
played into this one of them is
the expansive requirements the services
we require you need to pay your internet
bill you need to buy a phone you need to
you have a vehicle like all of these
things compound so you know my parents
growing up like they didn't they didn't
need a tv they didn't need phones they
didn't need anything they had empty
studio apartments or the matches on the
floor and it was like not living well
but it was like you didn't have to worry
about extensive bills so
regardless of inflation that there's
there's more there's more material
expenses that are that are sure
but i think i think there's there's also
like the prices i mean if you think
about it like this right where if you go
if a lot of those kids who bought into
that and all went to college because
they were told this is what we have to
do and these are a lot of the same kids
who are begging for for debt forgiveness
now which i'm against but just to say
they go let's say you go and you're a
hundred grand in debt now from from
college and then you enter a job market
post 2008 financial recession that is
not a good job market so you're like
working at starbucks so you're working
at starbucks and you have a hundred
grand in debt and you're living at home
and the average cost of a house uh you
know around you is like five hundred
thousand dollars and the you know the
you know the cost of like colleges what
colleges the cost of health care is what
health care is that kids look in there
go what is the plausible path
for say that young man working at
starbucks to get married and support a
family right but the cost of just
schooling and housing and health care
and all of the things that the
government has bid up to these insane
high prices like that to me is almost
like the essential problem with the soul
of america as joe biden likes to mention
it is that we have made the path to just
having a life where you start a family
and raise your kids and live a nice life
damn near impossible well regular people
they've solved that problem advocate
against having a family and nobody
there you go problem solved there you go
abortion solves this problem
kids right yeah right that's that's
what's that that's we're facing here's
all right here's the here's the solution
she has an abortion and it turns out
you're a woman not a man so there you go
no
issue if we hadn't been on the petro
dollar from 1975 what like the standard
of living the united states would have
been way less i would imagine like we
wouldn't have had access to like what
like a tenth would we have that
well okay so i guess in essence
the question
is tying into like
are we saying are you guys saying that
we should because this is kind of going
in the direction of
we should want less
is it going that way like is is our
definition changing because credit
credit credit inflation inflation
inflation inflation greed greed so now
you want more but you're chasing more
but now you got more debt and now it's
impossible well i see i think it's fine
to always want more and in many ways we
get more like with technological
advances but to your question and like
if there is um if you say if we had gone
off the gold standard but hadn't gone on
to the petro dollar well there's still a
lot of other questions like so then what
would we have done i mean if we had not
wasted let's say a trillion dollars a
year
on maintaining the empire and that
trillion dollars had been not extracted
from the american economy and just
handed over to basically weapons
companies and all of the and that had
been left within the american economy
then yes i think we'd be way richer than
we are for maintaining the american
economy but even an even stronger
argument is how about this what if we
had not gotten off of the gold standard
and what if we had not created the
department of education in the
department of homeland security and what
if we had not had this drastic expansion
of government and we had continued to be
a somewhat free society we would be
wealthier right now than we can possibly
fathom i'll put it into video game terms
for you with civilization you guys ever
play civilization what's the latest one
six six i love civilization so you build
a civil you start as like a nomadic
tribe you build a city you develop you
can you can choose to do technology
there's a bunch of different ways you
can win
the way i always play the game is i
build a bunch of cities have my borders
have minimal
military just to defend our borders but
no no excursions develop science flying
cars and you know coastal coastal uh
flood walls and advanced technology and
with advanced technology anybody who
tries to invade me we stop and we don't
go chase them down and that's how i play
the game see this is how i imagine
america uh used to be
and could be
you know and and um maybe trump isn't
the perfect avatar of bringing this
about but the very least being like
we'll protect our borders and we'll stop
wasting time over there we tried we put
there no it was an obvious like if you
don't get involved across the world if
you're not part of the community
somebody's gonna be like well i also
have access to the technology and i
would like to conquer yes but what i'm
saying is
the way i go about playing my
civilization is yes i will have military
capabilities but i don't need to go and
conquer all these other lands because
i'm scared they might attack me i just
if they come at me then i smack them
back and i focus on making my country
great but if you're if you're playing on
difficult and the enemy really wants to
destroy you they'll have like 16 bombers
ready they'll have nukes they'll have
all sorts of weapons that you can't
defend against no you cannot no matter
how
don't you tell me about civilization
because even you got to play on god mode
man immortal only if you play when you
when you listen if if you want to play a
game where the enemy has an unfair
advantage in their resource production
that's just a stupid analogy when i'm
talking about playing on normal and they
have the same rules that i have yes i
build nukes i build weapons and i mind
my own efforts we should go a pvp
version for we'll stream it we'll stream
it live we'll look at what happens but
it's but in in the real world it's it's
like this right it's like what adam said
and he was right from
he was right on the money and i forget
the i don't have the exact quote i'll
butcher it but he goes if we go around
searching for monsters to slay we will
become the dictators of the world and we
will lose our own soul and that's
exactly what's happened to the united
states of america that we've become
we've we've decided and look you can
watch this it was such a prophetic
warning that even as like when when the
republicans and the evangelical
christians really had so much control of
the country and the culture right in
post 911 they used this to say we're
going to go to iraq we're going to go to
afghanistan we're going to fight this
war on terrorism and what's happened to
our own soul since then it's completely
collapsed and i'll say this to right
wingers who like really care about the
culture war stuff they should care about
being anti-war more than anything else
because when does the like kind of
left-wing degenerate culture really take
hold when did you see the social
revolution it was during vietnam
when did you see the rise of the woke
in insanity it was in in
following the war on terrorism with all
of these failed wars look the even the
idea of like hitler rising that was all
a consequence of woodrow wilson getting
us into world war one we had we entered
into a war we had no business being in
we entered a world war that would have
ended in a stalemate almost certainly
and tipped the balance on one side
enforced the treaty of versailles on the
germans we we drew the russian forces
out and the bolsheviks took over russia
so now you have the rise of communism
and nazism it's all woodrow wilson's
fault for getting us in that way
we are supposed to be a city on a hill
we're supposed to be a free country and
if other countries want to emulate us
then great but you know what the idea
that we're going to bring freedom all
around the world when we can't even
protect it here you're telling me the
country that had lockdowns is going to
bring freedom to what the muslim world
give me
and this is this is the important point
for you ian too your
your argument would dictate that we we
gear up for a beaching of china
no no no i mean i know what you guys are
saying
they've got concentration camps right
now where they're raping women
performing they're forcing abortions on
them
and they're in concentration camps
they're expanding rapidly around the
world they're they're they they wanted
to
build the nicaraguan canal which would
have wiped out a natural water aquifer
just because and it was it ridiculous
how long it would have been had to had
to have been because we have the panama
canal they're doing exploit exploration
and land purchases in the united states
in south south america and africa
they're both they have the belt the road
initiative they are doing so much
that is expanding their power their
their
the south china sea taiwan not to
mention the concentration camps and the
skirmishes on the board were that india
so if if if that is your criteria we
should have already invaded them a long
time they haven't been invading anybody
though if hitler had exterminated the
jews without an invasion no one would
have stopped him
i mean what right do you have to go into
a sovereign nation and tell them how to
run their their show it's just
so that's the point of saying we're a
city on a hill because because to your
point that's what we've been doing
clandestine or overt for decades at this
point and by the way no one did stop
hitler from genociding the jews right i
mean i i guess the soviets liberated
like the last
few hundred of them or something like
that but he got away with his genocide
and it only happened after the war you
know what i mean like so it's if
anything the idea that the war prevented
the genocide of the jews i know a little
something about this as a jew whose
family is from uh uh germany um the no
genocide was prevented you know what i
mean so really the truth is that all we
can do and and this is unfortunate but
the reality is that
large swaths of of the world are
authoritarian nightmares and all that
happens when we raise up this
military-industrial complex in the name
of battling that is we become an
authoritarian nightmare as well
unfortunately it's like the analogy i
like to use is it's like if you were
sitting there in your house and you're
worrying about your neighbor's marriage
while your marriage is falling apart
you know like you're literally your
marriage is falling apart but you're
really concerned about how the guy down
the street is treating him if you see
the guy down the street it's like okay
we're married to abner and bewitched
that lady
oh the uh the actress
you know she's always watching from
across from
but if your neighbor down the street's
like breaking down the doors of other
neighbors then you're like uh are we
just gonna sit here like at what at what
point do we get involved in
okay so then but then at the same time
man if you're going to use this analogy
then at this then when do people start
checking america however we always just
imagine ourselves we're the righteous
like we're the ones who are stopping
other people from breaking down the
doors like who's broken down more doors
do you listen man between the war in
iraq and the war in afghanistan and the
war in yemen and the war in in syria and
the war in somalia and the drone
campaign in pakistan and the war in
yemen what do you think the total death
count is
we're the world's terrorists right now
so if anyone should kick down any doors
it should and by the way i'm not like a
lefty blame america first i love america
i love this country i hate our
government right i'm talking about our
government right now i'm not some
left-winger like there's problematic
toxic masculinity or something i'm
telling you this these are the
blood-soaked monsters in our government
and they're the ones who should be
checked and let's point out the purpose
of nato which was
well supposedly it was to stop the
soviet union from encroaching into
western europe hey we did that and now
what's nato doing oh they're encroaching
into eastern europe
no they became that we promised uh in in
when the soviet union collapsed we
promised both both verbally and in
writing that nato would not move one
inch to the east that was the deal we
made the soviet union we said look let
all your satellites break up okay let
them have have their sovereignty and we
promise you we won't move nato at one
inch to the east and every single
president since then has expanded has
has um included more eastern european
countries now finland into getting on
board that's right so i think finland
including trump by the way who brought
two more into nato who did he bring in
on the uh yeah who's you have to look
that up or the the trump was it estonia
under trump was it estonian no no no i i
might be wrong about that i feel like
the liberal economic order was spun up
to prevent world war iii which it kind
of has except we're in a fifth
generational world war right now this is
techno war i think the excuse was to
prevent world war iii but i think the
truth is that this is just kind of the
natural this is like it's the adams
quote we lost our soul so once we uh
once we won the first world war it was
like all right well
do we just go back to being a city on a
hill now i don't know we're the toughest
guys in the world and then once we did
it again won the second world war it was
like oh okay well now we have half of
europe stalin has half of europe and now
it's a competition to who can rule the
whole it's like you got they get drawn
into the game of world domination
empires doing empire [ __ ] and the basics
of it all is it's time it's been time to
[ __ ] pull back
the difference is the part that i think
a lot of times we don't see now is
the actual death
the actual [ __ ] murder the actual
babies
the actual people being [ __ ] killed
because otherwise media can spin up this
argument that the things that dave are
going is like breaking down
media can make it look like oh those are
the actual bad guys and we're just here
to protect us from those guys never mind
okay yeah we're gonna have this
conversation about
election meddling and all these other
different things but let's ignore the
fact that our government so-called deep
state whatever has been doing it forever
i think that part is the general public
is going to have to ask do you want to
be the republican to free folk and fall
back and hold those um parties or those
uh public servants in that position to
do that or are you okay with just being
the empire but empires generally fall
yeah that's right
can i just say real quickly there's that
even if you don't care about like the
the innocent
women and children being slaughtered in
all of these countries like
hypothetically if you're just like
that's not your thing okay look what
it's given us right like this whole like
domestic war on terrorism now that joe
biden is pointing in at donald trump
supporters what's he using
he's going to use the patriot act and
the department of homeland security and
everything that those guys supported
that they voted for in the name of
fighting the muslims that's right and
that's what's going to be turned on
their own people and what did every
single one of us say as activists in the
late 2000s and early 2010s hell what
obama was doing was this is exactly what
is going to happen you know i i
appreciated uh greg gutfeld who i love
who's uh he's got a show on fox news as
a lot of you know i'm sure but he said
he was like you know i was one of those
guys and he he named me as one of the
people like he was like you know all
these people would tell me like glenn
greenwald and dave smith and like oh and
i think he said that
and he'd go they all go you know if the
government can do this to muslims they
can do it to you and i was like no
they'd never do that and i really
appreciate it and he admitted it he goes
yeah he might have been right about that
i i gotta say there was a point hey man
even tucker right a lot of people who
were very much pro pro machine are now
going hey i think we were wrong about
that yeah right respect i give tucker a
lot of credit for that because he was
like a real supporter of of the war in
iraq i believe in 2003 2004 and he
turned around pretty early i think it
was like 2005. i think he went there and
he was like oh yeah this is i was way
wrong about this and now he's become
so weird in this world that the 8 pm fox
news hour is the biggest anti-war voice
in the corporate process and here's
here's what we said because we had an
old we had we had a boomer on the show
and we told her uh that feminists are
more are the pro-war faction now and she
didn't believe it because she was a
feminist and then it was it was richie
mcginnis and his mom and richie goes no
yeah that's right i said think about it
you have a group of people one wearing
red hats one wearing [ __ ] hats which
side is pro-war
the trump supporters are more likely to
be angry being like stop and the [ __ ]
hats are going to be like how much money
can we give to ukraine for this war
effort yeah and i'll tell you i wish the
like i i'm happy with the movement uh to
being more anti-war on the right i think
it's like the best development in the
last uh 15 years but i just once came
right i want i want them to be better
you know what i mean i think they're
still not quite good enough but yeah it
is crazy how much the left was co-opted
although i will say that what's kind of
interesting is that a lot of
the people who are really good on the
left
are now just labeled as right-wingers
right and i think you kind of fall into
that category like the door is
right-wing now that's right
glenn greenwald and jimmy dore and but i
think
right and i think you fall into that
category too like you were kind of one
of the people who would have considered
yourself on the left who as that switch
happened were like well no i'm not going
to go into being the pro cia pro war
council is not what we are when they
started coming after julian assange i
was like why why why is the left all of
a sudden mad at the guy who's good i
don't understand what's going on here
and then they were like because he
helped trump and i'm like and like yeah
yeah what i'm saying to you all is y'all
see you guys are explaining things from
a very highly level
a big understanding of this political
thing that's going on
right again simplifying it for the
general public the massive over over
corrections sorry air quotes that's
happening on both sides there's general
public
to your point about you that are going
like hey this is the standard that i
stand for i'm objective here it doesn't
matter who i'm not going to switch
because it's oh he said he was giving
trump he was helping trump no he was he
was saying the thing that was right
right
what we have to do is make sure that
we're translating this to the general
public that understands like hey they're
feeling that same way nah i was with
this but that i thought i was with that
but that's [ __ ] it's so hard when
you look like jennifer lawrence gave an
interview where she said we could have
had hillary clinton but people just
wouldn't vote for it because she had a
vagina and i'm like well for me it was
because she wanted to start a war with
russia and because she said we came we
saw he died and it was overseas she was
secretary of state while we were blowing
up kids and giving lucrative contracts
to our buddy like it's so it's
not
is it untrue and that there's plenty of
reasons to hate hillary clinton it is
the complete inverse of what is true
right what is true is that hillary
clinton was only there because she was a
woman she was married to the president
and then gifted a senate seat in a state
she didn't even live in off of that and
then ran for president off that and lost
to barack obama but because she was the
second best given the secretary of state
uh role the fact is that she walked into
the role because she was a woman but
yeah there's lots of reasons to
hate hillary this is where they are
so i i had a i have a friend who's a
hollywood actress and this is a couple
years ago and she said something like
passively like the only reason they
voted for him was hey brown people and
then i was like what does that mean like
what do you mean by that and she's like
the trump supporters like they don't
actually care about policy they just
hate brown people and i was like is that
what you think about these people
because like i'll give you an example i
was in anaheim and there were three
trump supporters two young guys one
older guy and i asked them why they
supported trump and they said actually
they were bernie supporters but when
given the choice between bernie sanders
hillary clinton and donald trump donald
trump was as close as they could get two
of bernie sanders
not that they were particularly close
but a lot of issues they were and so
they said i'll take it because those
matter to me had nothing to do with race
at all
you know
there were like there were hundreds of
districts that went for obama that
flipped to trump in 2016. i mean a
million people the idea that race was
the driving you know factor in that is
silly my point here is you're right we
got to find their level but when people
genuinely are misled and live in bubble
world echo chamber cult land because of
the media
it is not that easy well no no it's not
it's not going to be [ __ ] easy what
i'm saying is we just have a severe
opportunity here and i say severe
because and i choose that word carefully
severe meaning this opportunity you
might not even like get it again like
there is absolutely no way that you have
these type of conversations right
and people are seeing that pendulum keep
going both boom left right boom red blue
red blue we have a severe opportunity to
go well here's some other options here's
libertarian
here's okay here's independent
these people are tired you just have to
explain it to them yeah
you got it like you got it like okay you
may not be able to do it on facebook
because in about two weeks they're going
to start shutting anything that's
leaning anywhere right of center that
[ __ ] is getting suppressed well it's
true it and you know i like to say i
might have said this on the show before
once too but i go sometimes you'll like
um you could be looking through like you
know going on a youtube journey and
you'd go to like you know you scroll in
like these social justice warrior you
know like videos and then you'll scroll
on like some alt-right videos and like
all this and you go oh my god we're like
on the verge of a race war in this
country but then you go to the
supermarket
and you like you know like you like some
black guy walks in front of you and he
goes oh pardon me and you go oh no
you're good go ahead and then you open
this and you're like no you know i think
we're fine i'm like i don't think any of
this is real
remember he's like
well i don't think i am i think that the
vast majority of people in this country
really are sick of the culture
they care about the fact that prices are
getting out of control they care about
the fact that like the economy is not
working for them and the truth is that
we need this is what the whole is yes
that's true yeah it's the economy stupid
but see people say things like you know
bill burr said this recently on
trigonometry he's like you go on the
internet people the civil war or
whatever but then you go in the real
world people are just minding their own
business doing their thing it's like yes
it's no surprise to me that when you are
in a liberal area liberals are fine with
each other it's no surprise to me that
when you go to a conservative area
conservatives are fine with each other
but go to an area where the where the
streams the rivers are mixing and you're
seeing people get shot in the chest like
aaron danielson when those clashes start
happening it's like oh
yes new york is overwhelmingly liberal
so they're not fighting each other
they're still riots we i went down to a
conservative area where the cafes the
fast food restaurants all had like bible
study on the walls and i'm like man
chick-fil-a gets protests in the city
that's where the streams mix and they
don't get along and there's there's
violent riots and what's this as well
i'm not denying any of that but i'm
saying that there's way more way more
than those incidents
are people who are just really worried
about like their and you're right their
daughter who's like failing out of
eighth grade math and their son who's
like got to go to college next year and
what america needs this is what we're
trying to push is that what we really
need
is like solutions to the problems that
actually matter this is why this is why
i really highly encourage people to give
the libertarian party a look lp.org join
come check us out here's our message
okay let me just get this let me get
this out this is my big plug okay
we took over the libertarian party these
are my people and maja's people who are
in there now here's what we stand for a
whole different a whole different option
than the republicans or democrats how
about end all of the wars end all of the
remnants of the covid regime and the
kobit restrictions and all of the
corporate bail bailouts all of this
federal militarization of the police as
well as local military militarization of
the police and the crazy
well i'm saying like the entire domestic
war on terrorism and the foreign war on
terrorism and all of it
end the war on drugs repeal the patriot
act abolish the fbi and the atf and all
of these awful organizations that are a
disgrace to a professed free society and
all gun control like let's let's stop
locking people in cages let's stop let's
end all of these things that are pitting
americans against each other and give
being a free country a shot
that's what we need right now we need a
revolution of freedom in this those
those are the people that even when you
explain it that way i live in a lefty
city
people are clearly they know that we do
firearms training they know that oh
these pictures with donald trump jr they
they know all of this
there's no way shape or form in
explaining that to that group of people
they're like
nah that seemed i thought you would you
guys were like crazy but now that we've
had this actual genuine outreach
now that changes the dynamic my point in
saying that is i think that's the part
where because both so-called sides are
tired
that that gives us that severe
opportunity and that's where that
conversation
needs to continue this is why
on the surface i'm in favor of ranked
choice voting because my first choice
would be the libertarian party
particularly because the mises caucus
took over
but i have the fear right now that i
vote for the libertarian party democrats
could win
so this is the inherent problem of the
first past the post system is that my
best bet is just vote republican even if
it's donald trump because i don't want
to see the democrats taking maintain
control yeah but locally well well but
there's also like okay too
well there's different it's the same
thing but okay so there's there is
definitely given like the current
circumstances there's a certain way that
a third party needs to be used right so
like i think that the way what the
libertarian party should be doing
essentially like my vision for it now
that we have it is that if there are
really good republicans who are are
really good on you know say like
opposing war and opposing the the
militarization of the police and all of
these things that we care about then
okay then yes we should basically if
we're running and making the difference
in that race where we could give it to a
democrat essentially what we should do
is make demands to that republican say
we want you to get even a little bit
better on these issues we want promises
if you're the incumbent we want actual
things like we want and then kind of
support them and if you're like a neocon
rhino awful republican then we will cost
you your job i love you so don't ever
run these people again because we will
give you the other job but i will also
say that i i you know with someone like
donald trump um
i i don't know that there's even that
strong of an argument although i enjoy
him owning the libs and triggering
everybody you're talking about like when
you got him in there
we had 20 20.
we had fouchy on the job for all of 2020
and while donald trump was in there so
that to me i'd be like i wouldn't even
i wouldn't even consider like the idea
that oh well we better vote for donald
trump instead of joe biden and i'm
saying this from from europe
these are the same arguments though
every every [ __ ] four years this is
gonna be the same argument i agree i
agree at what point
you
say
i'm not eating sugar
the [ __ ] is delicious right
you stop those cookies man where are
they but you stop it's it's rough for a
bit but you stop
as opposed to going well i'm i'm going
down the street and been going down the
street five along even if it's locally
even if i mean at what point do we say
this isn't good enough we got to do
better
i agree with that except the analogy
would be more like
you've got the choice between
sugar and beer
and i'm like i'm not touching the
alcohol like i would eat sugar i i would
eat sugar before i drink alcohol alcohol
really messes me up i just it messes
everybody up people you look i got this
whoop thing and people are like you're
wearing that government tracker what are
you doing it blame luke luke told me to
get it and he's supposed to leave the
anti-government
but uh but anyway
i drank one beer i wake up and it's like
my whoop tells me i'm dying it's like
your respirator your respiratory system
was in decline your temperature was
spiking you're fatigued because beer is
poison but if the if the choice is
between the lesser of two evils have the
sugar which okay
you know i choose not to do sure because
i think it's bad
but if i have to have one of them and
then you know if you see the point is
like yeah i i don't i get your point i
don't look look look i don't agree with
you on the you know trump and biden
what's the difference essentially right
well there certainly are differences so
just just to be clear i'm not even
saying even if you're gonna argue that
you're like look it's better like i'm
not saying everything's perfect but
one's way worse than the other okay even
if i grant that i'm saying that look
putting trump in there
led to what
it led to biden we like at a certain
point we have to say look this is what
look basically the republicans and the
democrats have both committed in effect
treason against the american people and
like this is the united states of
america damn it at a certain point we
gotta stand up and say like no we're i'm
not saying i would never vote for the
lesser of two evils i would vote for the
lesser of two evils in some situation
this is too damn evil on both sides
there has to be some line in the sand
where i go no i'm sorry the guy who kept
fouchy as the head of the covid response
and put him on tv every day through 2020
when the biggest moment the biggest
crisis of donald trump's life came he
failed he got an f on that score you
criticized joe biden that means you're a
trump supporter yeah that is true i
suppose that's that's that's no and
obviously joe biden's awful and and all
of the people he's put around him are
just horrible and they've done like
basically everything wrong
and it's a disaster but i'm just saying
how long we don't have another we don't
really have an option right now to say
let's put this off for another four
years right with a slightly less version
this country will be look look i think i
think it really comes down to is like
i agree with you on all the all of like
the the ideal positions and then you're
you're revolutionary and i'm a reformer
so i look at donald trump like i i like
the school choice move i think it's very
important banning critical race theory
trainings in at the government level
that's that's critical uh-huh and and
it's because a lot of that stuff is
outright illegal seeing corporations esg
scores having trump is is
those are good things pushing back
against that i listen i i agree okay
with that i i think you're you're right
that i'm a revolutionary and you're a
reformer i'd settle for being a reformer
he's not even that that's the problem
i'd settle for it's not as if people
treat me i know they say uh like i had a
debate with uh sticks uh do you know him
he's great i i like him a lot but we had
a debate some of his uh we debated over
trump and his people were saying to me
they're like dave you're just making the
perfect the enemy of the good and my
point is like
no
i'm making the bad the enemy of the good
listen what i care about is liberty
because liberty is what leads to a
prosperous and stable society don it's
not like donald trump they they're
acting like like donald trump let's say
cut the government by 50
and i'm going that's not good enough i
want a hundred percent right you know
what i mean right but that's not it he
grew the government right it's not he
didn't it's not it's not like he did
something in the right direction and i'm
saying it wasn't enough i'm saying he he
when he took control of the took control
when he was elected president i don't
really have control of the executive
branch but he was the president and the
republicans had the house and the senate
and spending from barack obama went up
right like i'm sorry he's not even
moving us in the right direction if the
car is headed off the cliff he's going
faster than we were under barack obama
hold on you said
that voting for trump got us biden and
that's not a good thing but i'm kind of
like my my argument a lot of the antifa
people is that donald trump was their
vote not joe biden it was really weird
to see auntie for people be like well i
don't like joe biden but trump is a
fascist and i'm like if you think trump
is going to destroy this country you
think he's burning it down and breaking
it into a million pieces
then you'd want to vote for him because
if the end result is just joe biden and
the system is collapsing well then
perhaps that's what restores the
republic
well or leads to something far worse
than that i think that is always targets
before the dawn but i think both people
think about it both positions have to be
taken at the same time we we in again we
too late in the game to just pick one or
the other at this point there has to be
people that are willing to say hey i'm a
reformer these are the areas where i'm
going to refirm reform you're a
revolutionary these are the areas tell
me more about this revolutionary [ __ ]
the people in the middle that don't even
know that both of these other options
exist are the people that we both have
to collectively and individually gauge
and get that's the part that's the
because there's people on the sidelines
going that are going to listen to this
and they're going to first they're going
to be like well maj wasn't even saying
[ __ ] i don't [ __ ] have to
you guys are going to say stuff and i'm
going to go
this is what they mean by this breakdown
there are people in the middle that are
like i reform on some of these areas i'm
revolutionary in these maybe locally
maybe in a small town maybe in new
hampshire maybe we go okay we're going
to just revamp this maybe what desantis
is doing in florida he's definitely
gonna win but he's like okay now i'm
going local
now i'm gonna talk to all of these other
people too that's that's a model that we
can emulate okay to you to your point
okay no
trump is absolutely not as horrible as
biden but to your point you're saying
yeah but dude's still [ __ ] spending
us into [ __ ] oblivion right
at the same time okay you're the realist
these are how some of these things go
currently you're like well they
shouldn't [ __ ] go this way currently
and they never should have and hear
how's their wrong here's how they're
wrong you have to be able to explain
that to the general public that are in
the middle
we're not arguing against and you guys
aren't obviously we're not arguing
against each other we're listening we're
talking really to the people that are
watching that we don't even know are
watching to inform them about here's how
this person was horrible here's how this
person was great here's how locally you
can avoid that and here's how you can
completely abolish that
but just to your point that we're not
arguing here i mean look we're basically
on the same page with all this stuff
right and so that it almost becomes a
question of like strategy like what do
we do with this yes because we're really
in a crumbling we're in a crumbling
society and this is a very dangerous
situation
and i just think it's not the way no i
agree with you but i do think that the
way forward i agree seizing the federal
government is not the way forward i mean
that by winning an election becoming
is president try to have as much of an
awakening of as big a group of people as
you can to recognize what the core of
the problem is here like everyone kind
of senses that there's a major problem
in this society and what we need to do
is kind of wake people up to realize
that and and i will i would argue very
passionately that really the problem is
that we've completely drifted away from
everything this country was supposed to
be yeah which is the declaration of
independence and the ability to have the
idea of individual liberty sure so uh
i'm curious your thoughts on rankings
finisher oh yes
grab another bottle what's your what do
you guys think on a ranked choice of
voting i think it would be an
improvement over the the current
situation sure i mean i don't know that
that necessarily solves everything but
um i think that the um
like i mean look like you said before we
kind of have this uniparty what a lot of
libertarians like to call the duopoly
you know of like two parties who are
basically a monopoly um the this
the system's completely rigged against
third parties i look what they're doing
to larry sharpe in new york where they
just raised the requirement right to get
i believe he was in court today yep i
don't know what ended up happening with
that but um
several times yeah yeah we love larry
sharp um but uh so yeah i think that
would be an improvement but i think uh
from my perspective almost like on a
more of a meta level it's like people
have to like kind of wake up to
accepting that
this is only going to work when enough
people go we're not falling into this
game anymore where you go okay if from
your perspective you believe that this
evil party is five percent less evil
than this evil party then we'll fall in
line with them because this is what they
do this is how the games have been
played right it's like bush is such a
disaster that you know what those those
swing voters will swing over to obama
and then obama's such a disaster that
those swing voters will swing over to
trump and then trump is just such a
headache and everyone's just so over him
and the response to him and all of this
that like uh i guess dead people will
just vote for joe biden uh just kidding
i don't know
he really won the dead vote
um but you know what i'm saying like
this game and there's got to be a way to
kind of break out of this right but i
think but yes yeah we have the
technology for the 50 governors to get
on a skype chat to get on uh slack to
get on some video chat every day
it's the legislators let's get them on a
site
the problem is that we have the
technology but people have been looking
at it as if we don't like they're stuck
in this past
state of mind where we've got to send
letters and wait two weeks to hear back
and like dude the solutions are in front
of us literally right now all four of us
here hear me out guys here we go so
here's what i was thinking like you know
the problem is you're right you go you
go back and forth we're swinging it's
getting crazy one guy gets in there's a
bunch of bad stuff so then everyone's
like i'll go over this guy then he's a
bunch of bad stuff and i'm like what if
there was a simpler way to do it you
know what if we just had like one person
who just you know we put in charge to
run the system and then we didn't have
to worry about voting or anything like
that like you know when they got too old
their kid would just take over for him
and then you know their kids and then
have you been reading hapa this is a uh
i got a question about tim the monarch
about war
you were talking about like cutting back
on the the military basically in general
which i i i'm very i'm pretty much
anti-war but i'm also these days i've
been thinking of myself maybe i'm a
realist that we've been running the war
machine the united states was tasked
with the liberal economic order the
british empire the americans the
australians whatever
if we just stopped would not boeing just
start selling planes and weapons to the
chinese ccp and then they would take
over and become a military dominating
force putting troops in mexico
that's the same thing as the pendulum
swinging but that's not the the idea
this idea is like so ridiculous dude
it's like so okay so then i guess we
just gotta prop up boeing because
someone else could prop up boeing if we
don't prop up
china listen man i know
this is like china taking over the world
is just not happening look we are so
much richer than china is if you the
amount of poverty that they have in
their country compared to us what about
this now we can't afford to do this
we're 30 trillion dollars in debt we're
going bankrupt doing this china is doing
the exact opposite of what we're doing
they're going around and investing in
other parts of the world well we spend
ourselves into debt china by the way is
in a bubble economy that is 10 000 times
bigger than the bubble that we have
right here this thing is going to pop
the idea china couldn't even get through
dominating their own region let alone
dominating the entire world like don't
get me wrong china is a really messed up
government they're a communist
government that basically figured out
that they should allow prices and
businesses so they're not quite
communist in the way that like mao
zeitung was communist but they're still
kind of communist and it's kind of
fascist i guess and they're evil and
they do a lot of bad things but this
idea that like oh if we didn't prop up
the military-industrial complex that
then china would prop up our
military-industrial complex look man
here's what matters we got two oceans on
either side of us we got the biggest
nuclear arsenal in the world or at least
one of the biggest nuclear arsenals in
the world we got the you know we we have
400 million guns or something in that
neighborhood no one's a threat to us
period the idea that china is going to
come halfway around the world oh no they
come from it comes from the orbit
it's just you just we see it before it
gets here i don't know if that's true
listen man if china wants so so in that
case that could they could do it right
now of course that has nothing to do
with it the history of earth is
basically there is a military dominator
it almost at all times there's somebody
that's the most powerful military force
and they are controlling things there
were empires uh way before america
became an empire but from the beginning
of america we were still a free country
that's not our job to worry about man
and like i'm sorry i know like that that
rubs people the wrong way because they
have this uh idea that we have to be the
good guys of the world even though we're
objectively the bad guys uh in the world
but the truth is that like i said before
we can't even protect freedom in our
country we're not spreading it around
the world um let's see the the best
thing america ever did for the world was
exporting the best parts of our culture
was it was
that people wanted to listen to our
music and wear our blue jeans and be
cool like us that's the best influence
we could have on the world being a free
country here do you think on the dawn of
colonization of mars that it's okay not
to be strive to be the military
dominating force on earth as a country
or should we give that power to a
corporation or to another country
um i would say that uh i'm to keep us a
free country i am okay with sacrificing
colonizing martial
when you say free country do you mean
that you're not
you're not like like anyone can do any
like what is your like because in in a
totally open system it can be co-opted
very easily by outside no i mean when i
say freedom i mean liberty i mean
negative rights i mean the right to life
liberty property you know so like no
spying on people that kind of stuff you
get rid of that but sure what happens
then when the ccp is spying and
infiltrating our media and making us
think things like communism good i've
always thought communism was good i mean
you know who's really done more to [ __ ]
to infiltrate our country that i mean
how do they even infiltrate it they they
infiltrate what
uh what do they pay commercial do they
pay off for president's son farms on
social media that's always what they
that's what they tell you right
universities the government program that
is universities that's completely backed
up by loans coming from the government
oh yeah social media companies
government is about comments
this is all nonsense dude the idea that
social media comments have had this huge
influence you know the truth is that
well all that's happened is that's been
used as an excuse for the government to
crack down on social media companies and
happiness what do you mean huh we we see
it all the time companies caving to 30
people over nonsense they they get so we
we were doing we're doing an event those
are real people you're talking about
they're like social justice warriors
like there's no way to tell there's no
way to tell and and some of it very well
could be china they call the 50 cent
army you know what this is yeah i've
heard of it they they go out there they
post pro ccp stuff but they're uh we've
also heard from other people who are
familiar with china's actions that
they're encouraging wokeness in the
united states tick tock for instance
allows it here but doesn't allow it
there so
yeah well look i experienced this where
you get one person pretending to be 50
to try and force a business and it works
okay i'm not so i'm not arguing that
that has never had an effect on say like
a business i'm talking about more like
i'm like subverting the entire country
but if you look at the main ways what
they're what people try to infiltrate is
they try to infiltrate the institutions
of the government or i suppose you could
say universities which is again
basically a giant government program
it's all completely propped up by
government-backed loans or the whole
industry wouldn't exist i think that
yeah look you'd need to have a culture
to guard against that type of stuff and
that right and that's what you need is a
culture if you want to guard against
communism you'd really like to have a
culture that believes in liberty when
you're also strong families and and
strong values and all the government
does is undermine all of this this is
like i mean from the welfare state
undermining families to you know the the
kind of like undermining churches and
communities and all of this this is what
big government has gotten us so in
essence i guess your question would be
in essence how do we prop up against
things like that china chinese
uh bots and all those different things
to infiltrate that to the point
it's our government doing it more than
anybody else and if if we're going along
with it and we're weakening it because
the government is telling us to right
again 2020 instead of us genuinely
saying [ __ ] no i'm not wearing a mask
i'm not wearing a [ __ ] vaccine my bit
my business didn't close the entire time
we didn't stop at black guns matter we
kept going that is a culture of we are
free now if something is really there
we're going to be safe and responsible
we're going to mitigate our freedoms or
our safety based on that freedom right
that culture compared to hey ccp where
we build stuff and people jump out of
the [ __ ] building and there's nets to
catch them from killing themselves when
you compare that to a young person you
show them that difference as opposed to
them being told yeah socialism is great
and there's nothing to really counter
that no real information then of course
it's going to be more difficult but
that's not that's not that's not
overwhelmingly coming from china yeah
would you use like american propaganda
to push that message on people
what do you mean by propaganda well like
little kids are the most susceptible
they made cigarette commercials illegal
and like this whatever well they making
little kids [ __ ] do the pledge of
allegiance
yeah so
propaganda to get people on board with
american ideals i think i think that
that word propaganda's kind of loaded
right because me saying i believe that
everyone should have a firearm to be
able to defend themselves and telling
them about their human right to self
defenses of me articulating that well is
a form of propaganda right and it's in
alignment with my agenda which is
freedom and liberty right so when you
say propaganda what do you mean by do
you mean like bernays like just [ __ ]
lie to you propaganda yeah like how deep
would you take it i mean because i think
what right now they're using google to
subvert what they think is american
whatever ideas to combat the ccp that's
putting in like hey kids be a communist
but then but but hold on let me just ask
because you're saying when they're using
who do you mean is using google to
combat the series we know the fbi is in
tight with social media networks telling
them what to post what not to post
yeah right yeah it's very murky as to
who well and they certainly at least
according to mark zuckerberg when he was
asked why they suppressed the hunter
biden story the first thing he said was
well the fbi came to us and told us
there was going to be this big russian
dump and when there was this dump they
said this was all the dump they all said
this was the russian propaganda so again
they told their the staff not to
investigate it so right they knew what
they were doing so you know if your
concern is that like china is going to
propagandize us i just like i go okay
but like this is to justify the regime
in washington dc but then like look at
who's actually propagandizing our kids i
mean like look at who's actually
propagandizing them right now it's the
public schools corporations
so i think we've we've talked a lot
about the things we don't like a lot of
the problems
give me your guys's vision of what
america should be
well look i mean what america should be
is uh it should be the bill of rights in
the declaration of independence i mean
that that as a starting point like
that's what we should have in this
country we should like it didn't have to
be this way okay this is this is there
was nothing that was like written in the
stars that everything had to go this way
and i i'm not saying it has to be my
utopia that i want it to be this perfect
you know libertarian anarchist system
sure that would be best but i'm just
saying we didn't have to respond to 911
by starting seven stupid wars and
killing all of these people and decree
passing the patriot act and all of this
we could have just let's say
we just say
even went into afghanistan and killed
osama bin laden and torabora when we had
him uh cornered and came home the war on
terrorism was over by uh by christmas of
2001. we could have just not had
artificially low interest rates in the
early 2000s and blew up this housing
bubble and had the financial crisis in
2008 we could have just not responded to
covid in an insane way we could have
just had a government who came out and
went you know there's this upper
respiratory virus we think if you're at
risk you should probably stay home
that's our advice to you everyone else
you know be careful maybe wash your
hands if you feel sick stay home we
could have not tanked the entire economy
and printed six trillion dollars in a
year and destroyed everything so all i'm
saying is like
less of the evil stuff we could do a lot
less of this it doesn't have to be it's
not a choice between what we have now in
perfection it's that we should always
have liberty as like the guiding
principle and being very skeptical of
what the government does so that's what
we need that and all that comes down to
is just scaling back i don't need more
legislation to do that again if we start
from that bill of rights the declaration
of independence and letting that be okay
this is the litmus test is this hey if
we're giving more and more government
more and more dollars more more power
more and more control 80 000 more irs
agents how does this get us back to more
liberty
if that's the it's a very basic question
it's a very basic answer nah i'm not
doing it tell me tell me where it says
in this that we should be giving this
over there if that's not the answer then
no we're not doing it
it's interesting and i i completely
agree and i would just add to that that
like the mission here to me really is
that look i mean think about like how
the massive propaganda campaign to push
the copic lockdowns the massive
propaganda campaign to push the vaccines
where it's it's like you have to hear
about this constantly completely
oversold of like you know if you get
this you can't possibly get covet and
you can't spread it if you question this
you're an anti-vaxxer and all of this
they use these massive
propaganda campaigns because they know
how important it is to have the
population believing that they have
legitimate authority over them and
believing that they're doing the right
thing so i think the mission here is to
counter the propaganda
and to wake people up like you said the
mission isn't to take over the federal
government and then you know
you know wield power over all of the
people and do it in the right way the
mission here is to wake people up to
realize that what we ought to be
striving for is to be very skeptical of
all of these authoritarians who promise
us that they're doing it for our own
good if we had a society like that we'd
be in much better shape
did he convince you oh yeah
i mean i've been convinced since the day
i met you bro
but uh i've got a lot of concern about
about the future of the constitution
because i think going back to what we
had 200 years ago might be a mistake
that we should make a new global
constitution with american values
um like a global constitution yeah the
manila principles is interesting for the
internet it's like freedom of code as
opposed to freedom of speech or in
addition to because if you don't know
what your software is doing behind the
scenes when you're using it you're being
betrayed by your master you shouldn't
have a master you should be the master
of your code the code stuff is a really
good point like that's interesting with
facebook we don't know how we're being
manipulated and we know facebook
experimented on people by showing them
depressing content yeah yeah i've read
about that a little bit that is
interesting so i i think ian's 100 right
that we need to figure out i mean but
this could be an amendment to our
constitution we could we could write an
amendment saying
people have a right to know is
algorithmic you know code is what the
code of these systems do or are doing
like why would they have to be global
though i imagine we're globalizing
inevitably regardless we're creating the
new world order right now the world
economic forum really wants to be a part
of it and if we fight internally and
ignore it they're going to do it without
us and we'll be there but if we are
involved in the process we'll craft it
in our image that's part of the plan i
think yeah but see now you're you're
it smells like you want to like take
over the global government and use it
for good watch out with that i don't
think they're going to let you at the
table
[ __ ] ring bro the ring changes you
exactly i don't want to top down i want
a decentralized organization of states
across the world dude and mars new vlog
idea
ian eventually does become union
president and it corrupts him
like washington but then like it ends
with you falling into the lava and you
know
you're fighting you're fighting over
there
that's hot no no no no no no
i think that in essence
and i'm saying this as a black dude that
my ancestors during the time when these
things were written like that objective
stance of going okay declaration of
independence [ __ ] thomas jefferson's
pen was [ __ ] amazing but he owned
humans at the same time that he wrote it
so as me going like yo there's
contradictions here but what was written
was dope i think that america the
founders wrote something that was really
really dope and i think that if we're
going to be exporting [ __ ] you know you
know all over the place like hey this is
what we believe in outside of us just
being cool let's export this concept of
liberty and holding your so-called uh
public servants and even in your country
if you want to emulate this a few years
ago in china there were certain parts
dudes was waving [ __ ] american flags
like yo we want the second amendment
here type [ __ ] i think that should be
some of our chief export type [ __ ] and
and that doesn't mean it has to be
globalized it just means like yo this is
what we're doing over here we got guns
over on this side because we want to
keep our government a little bit more
honest you know what i'm saying in
exporting that and i don't know if every
country is going to emulate that but i
think that would be one of our our dope
exports well look and even if you look
at uh martin luther king and even
malcolm x i mean how did they make such
strides is that they beat america over
the head with their own constitution
they said well look you said it right
here in your own document that you're
not allowed to do this to me right now
so like it was a powerful example even
if like the founders were hypocrites
particularly on that issue on the issue
of slavery and race relations in general
but just think about it like this i mean
imagine if we were just a free country
and we were much more prosperous and
happy and stable than we are now because
we have this giant monstrosity of a
state imagine the power we could have
simply just lecturing and even
ridiculing the rest of the world and
saying to them imagine the power we
could have on the chinese people by
going look at you guys you're
impoverished and we're rich because we
believe in liberty right your communist
party is not providing anything to you
way more effective than if we were the
murderers of the world saying we see you
as a threat yeah we're gonna go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
and today we're shouting out tom
mcdonald he actually texted me he said
tell the world what up he's agreeing he
will also wear a suit if uh he hits the
hotel i believe lydia i believe we said
dress no is it suit
i can't remember the beginning perfect
yes so uh so shout out guys uh check out
his new song riot it's currently number
two trending on youtube it was four when
we started number two now i want you to
play this for after the show i want you
to play the song for me it's not it's
not a super political song you know no i
just want to hear the song like i like
music oh yeah yeah yeah
we have this uh tweet from dylan bellew
what is this i said smith toure 2024 oh
yeah
what do they mean what would we be doing
in 2024 maybe maybe you guys are going
to start a small business together yeah
you want to do something in 2024
together we might be doing like this uh
i mean do we do we do a llc or do we do
escort uh you know i got to talk to him
i got to talk to my tax guy because it
depends on how the revenue comes in i
think what's most
i think for a small business you guys go
llc and maybe you can do like you know
you build model ships well i'll tell you
this how about this for people who want
to store if let's say you wanted to say
hypothetically if you wanted to see me
and maj maybe run like let's say a
campaign of some sort in 2024 this is
what i need i need to see everybody join
the libertarian party lp.org
join sign up right now if you guys get
in there if we raise this this is what i
say 20 20 000 members if i get 20 000
members into the lp new members
then uh
i i will start a business with maj 2024
yeah it'll be a liberty oriented so i
want to give a shout out to eric miller
he said tim if tom hits number one you
have to wear a suit on stream and that's
where the idea basically came from so
shout out eric that was your idea i
really do appreciate it genius and i
thought it was a really good idea and
i'm like we will actually film like
going to get tailored and like me and
ian will go
i think this that's going to be
hilarious
by the way i'd also say for people who
even like i i understand the argument
that you're making and even people who
are like listen if it comes down to
trump biden i got to support trump if
you just think that what we're saying
here
should be like in the conversation right
you know what i mean that you think like
okay even if that's the case you need
someone kind of pushing the republicans
to be a little bit better on some of
these issues
come join the libertarian party and
listen to what we're doing and at what
point are you just not going to just be
saying well
it'll never be another third like the
republican party was a third party like
at a certain point that is true like
at what point are you just going to be
like
oh as you said we live in revolutionary
times
party fourth party it essentially is a
third party right like donald trump was
a third-party candidate within one of
the two parties right he did it and
bernie too was a third party and just
didn't do it
all right christina says my favorite
podcaster setting up my favorite rapper
is so cool can't wait to see when tom
finally comes on the show love you all
happy friday so
this all happened because
you know we put out a song we were i was
shouting it out saying we want to invade
the cultural spaces and then i was just
like i don't know tom very well i you
know maybe have talked to him one time
before this but i was just like he's a
guy who puts that music
you guys have probably heard his stuff
i'd imagine right have you i'm i'm not
sure i might have he's got it's rap a
lot of it's it's it's like i don't
describe it but scrap rap but the but
that doesn't sound the lyrics are just
so good it addresses political and
cultural issues his voice is like a
knife it's cool but the lyrics are
really good yeah and so i was just like
if you don't want to buy my song because
you don't like it buy his music get him
the number one we just need to invade
these cultural spaces yeah right and so
then when i heard he was putting out a
song i was like i'm gonna i want to see
tom hit the billboard charts i'm gonna
shout it out no i think i think that's
awesome yeah by the way shout out to
eric july i think he's doing that with
like in the comic world in the rip
reverse thing and his music and stuff
too i think all that stuff is is really
like so important
and talented actually like really
talented guys who are doing it yeah like
actually good not just like i'm i'm in
alignment with your politics that's
right get it yeah it's real time yeah
it's basically just if you want to win a
culture where you got to make culture
so everybody's doing that to the point
the liberty movement isn't just because
i know we spoke a lot about like parties
but when you start changing the mind of
people no one that's listening to this
conversation tonight is going to be like
nah
i totally disagree with the vast
majority of what they're talking about
they're gonna be like nah you you all
have conversations you're like there's
so many [ __ ] rhinos rhinos are
everywhere rhinos rhinos around us okay
cool either you're gonna push them to go
in this direction or you're gonna go let
me try this libertarian thing even if
it's not the party i do think that you
should join but at the same time the
overall philosophy and the ideology is
gonna lean us in the direction of
the bill of rights and like this overall
liberty yeah even if you're a republican
or god forbid a democrat i still push
them to be a little bit better right
like that's what we all got to do right
all right kerry green says love that
shirt make criminals afraid again i need
one shut up and take my money
can people buy that is that yeah yeah
they can go to uh
blackgunsmattershop.com it's on the
website right now go grab it which black
guns matter if you're not familiar go
check them out they are really they do
incredible stuff such as organization is
amazing yeah well you know why it's
great because it just it attacks the
left from the left right like it makes
them feel insecure about their own thing
it's like and then they go like well
wait but that's what we're the ones who
are supposed to care about that but we
have a monopoly on being the ones who
care about black people yeah bro the
funniest thing ever it's like having
telling somebody like yo you know as the
black dude you have the means and the
right to defend your life
from bad people and it's like well even
if you think that's all police okay if
you believe that all right
there was there was a uh i'm sorry i
don't know no no even if you think it's
all police yeah you think it's all
policing and you're like
yeah they're killing us it's like well
you can defend your life it's like well
no guns are bad nah i know they're not
bro you have the human right and the
bill of rights
to defend your life there was a there's
a story about some dude who got shot by
the cops or whatever and then i can't
remember who it was but it was like
white or something and then i posted
something about how it was it was
ridiculous what this cop did i can't
remember and then some lefty responded
with
tim is such a racist he only cares when
white people get shot yet he wouldn't
want gun rights for black people and
then i'm just like
what in the and people are insane i
responded i was like bro i want every
single black panther armed to the teeth
with multiple weapons marching down the
street right now and then he responded
based well dude there we go it's so
freaking people are so binary like they
think if you have one take then you have
to have like the other
decision well
so i remember because i was really harsh
on um all through 2020 on black lives
matter and the riots and all of that and
being like this is insane first off just
because it's awful that you're like
destroying businesses and
you know killing people and assaulting
people and all of this and also because
you're destroying the credibility for
the movement of like holding cops
accountable right because now and then
when um uh what's his name chauvin got
convicted i tweeted something and i was
like yeah good he absolutely deserved to
get convicted and they're like oh dave
you're totally backing down on all of
your views you're like wait a minute so
you think just because i was against
rioting and destruction of property that
i think the guy who kneeled on the
dude's neck
on the ground shouldn't go to jail like
no dude that guy would lock up some guy
for a gun possession charge and throw
him in a cage for 20 years and i never
lose sleep you can go right in prison
like i could care less my favorite was
when you tweeted uh something about the
left is not gonna handle losing very
well and then someone responded with
here's how your side handles losing you
know who it was who was it it was bette
midler she said no bette midler it's
like
i got
my accountant texted me and he goes
about you on is right
yes yes he is now do we have those tax
returns here all right you should
you should do you should have responded
with omg bette midler i'm such a big fan
hocus pocus
classic child i literally said memories
i swear to god my actual response is not
far off from that i went i just made my
wife and uh my daughter and son listen
to wind beneath our wings
i said we all danced which i actually
did we played it in the house and we all
danced all right solid turn yeah it is
looks like we got some big fans andrew
uh bro brasol says it's not just that
dave doesn't lie to your face like the
talking heads in the media what makes
dave so great is that he doesn't lie to
himself i respect it oh well thank you
that's nice to say i i do occasionally
you know
i'm telling myself what i'm trying to
pump myself up just manifestation bibi
says i posted a meme today making fun of
dc for declaring a state of emergency
over the migrant buses it was the james
franco first time meme fb claimed it was
promoting self-harm removed it and
restricted next please see that is
pretty hilarious
that was that was a pretty great like
real-life troll sending the immigrants
into dc i gotta say i enjoy it harold
wiley says just purchase tom mcdonald's
song if brett has to bleach his hair tim
can wear a suit uh so pop culture crisis
which is one of the shows we have here
at tim castle hosted by brett and mary
they had a bit that uh i don't know how
it came up but that if they hit 15
crisis parties brett would bleach his
hair and a crisis party is every hundred
dollars in super chats these lights go
off and then every so every time there's
a super chat money guns shoot money at
everybody
and then once a hundred dollars is
reached there's a party where those like
lights go off and it plays a noise and
then the money guns go crazy
and so they said if they get 15 of those
in one show brad has a bleachers here
they got 26.
that means that's 2 600 in super chat so
now my brother went out to pick up
pizzas and then he came back here's the
sauce and in the bag is bleach is hair
dye yes
so uh i agreed if tom mcdonald hey look
hot 100 number one is not an easy feat
no no not at all no i think you would
need to sell like a hundred or more
thousand singles
he's independent yep um so not only that
but the problem is it's kind of rigged
because they're probably going to pull
some bs where they're like well you know
that one doesn't count they want to see
you in a suit though you're good no he
means like billboard
they'll be
yeah absolutely yeah so so one of the
things that happened to tom is um he
sold more albums than anybody else and
they told him his numbers didn't count
and put him on the list or something
because of what what was their how did
they play that it's that so
you have to watch he did two videos
talking about how it went down and so i
don't know the exact nuance of it but
they were saying things like what's your
upc code we don't believe these numbers
so we're not going to accept them but
it's like it's complicated basically
people
traditionally would report like hey here
the the total sales we had yes sound
scan yeah yeah and then apparently
they didn't buy it and so there's weird
issues because like based on how many
views he gets he's number two trending
on youtube right now this song should be
billboard hot 100 right
but for some reason like let's see so
it's the song came out today
uh not next week but the following
tuesdays when they'll release the chart
for this reporting period yeah and
we'll you know
everybody's got to buy his song but i'm
going to be shouting out tom all week
because i just want i want to force
these people
that want you're going to love this so
we have a communications company they do
pr stuff for us and we have a song we
put it out one of the responses to it
was like hey tim pool has released a
song like it's available here it's the
first release and the new new program
teamcast records the response was the
covid19 vaccine is safe and effective
and is an effective treatment for
reducing the severity of coping and
that's all they said and that was it and
it was just like
are they saying they're not gonna i
don't know i don't know they're trying
why why are they emailing us right but
that's how crazy it is yeah it's it's a
weird cult like and then you know uh tom
was like is your song about the vaccine
and i was like bro it's a love and pain
song it's just like generic rock music
and that's the and that's the point now
now that's the over correction that the
general public in the middle sees and
goes nah that's [ __ ]
even if they disagree with you the vast
majority of people will go nah but
that's kind of [ __ ] up well do you
look you look at the numbers of um i
forget the exact numbers but it's um of
the the adult percentage of americans
who were uh double vaccinated with the
first round i think it was 70 something
percent and then who got their boosters
was half that
so you see there's a whole lot of people
even of the people who like went along
with it at the beginning who are
starting to kind of see they're like
nah
i'm not going to keep
at the airport at the airport when it
was everybody had to and i kept getting
kicked out of airports and airplanes
right that's why we bought the rv
because that was like they wouldn't let
you fly it was at the mountain we went
to the airport and they're like yeah you
can't get on our airline but this is
this is the crazy thing but now but now
you see those people now that there's no
mandate it's like eighty percent ninety
percent nobody's wearing it but but look
this is the crazy thing
they they email me that and then you
know so i was talking to tom earlier um
not that long ago actually a few hours
ago and i was like not only is the song
not about any of this but my position
the entire time on vaccines was it's
good that trump got it out it's good
that biden sped up the timeline for it
and it's up to you to talk to your
doctor to figure out what makes sense
for you and your health health
conditions
that that's been my position the entire
time just oh yeah they don't care it
doesn't matter
but telling people to talk to their
doctor about what's right for them is
considered anthony you did two things
you [ __ ] up two out of three
one
you said talk to your doctor like get an
actual medical professional's
perspective you didn't just run with
[ __ ] you if you don't take this that was
strikes matter
and your second strike was you said and
i disagree with it when you said
trump got it out fast you were giving
trump some credit for some [ __ ] that i
don't even i'm like yo he could have
just been like yo whatever
point being is two out of three [ __ ] you
and you're emailing us about your song
covey vaccines are [ __ ] safe and
effective and don't you dare
question the [ __ ] narrative who do
you think you're [ __ ] tim
you have to be 100 standing up
behind them or on your knees for them
any kind of like i see what you're
saying you know no no no you don't see
what i'm saying tell me i'm right or
else
that was that was so much of what their
problem with trump was is that even when
he continued the wars and continued the
empire he didn't tell everyone that he
believed in it right like he'd always
kind of be like but i don't really
believe in it like i don't really think
we should be doing this yeah let's read
some where we got cardinal says shout
out to the tim cass crew dave smith and
big daddy tourey
happy to hear that you got your rv back
big ups to you the work you do and your
solutionaries good people are looking
out for you let's hit that gofundme goal
did y'all hear about that no no my rv
got stole yesterday oh no wait really
yeah holy crap they picked the wrong
person to steal an rv from
which which class
class a forge yeah thor challenger
beautiful flats because this is when i
kept getting kicked off of planes we got
the rv
we're going to do the classes all over
the country we're not shutting down
we're going everywhere
still doing it so it's gearing up for
the winter time so we like all right
since we're getting back on planes
because people aren't afraid anymore
we're going to use the rv when we're not
doing classes regionally if you're
homeless if you need a place if you're
arguing you and your girl going through
it you need a hot meal it's cold in
philly
we're gearing up for that
go check on the rv
uh
is gone
like gone and i'm like what the [ __ ] and
i'm thinking okay the city towed it
and so i start chasing this process of
you know the city's like yo we don't
have it but they could have it and not
have put your tags in or whatever
so i'm like yo i think somebody stole it
so i go to the precinct and they're like
yo if commute if someone said it was
abandoned which i don't know why they
would it's a 200 000 rv
um i didn't we didn't pay 200 000 for it
but we bought it used but
um
if someone says it's abandoned
the police will tow it not like the
parking authority for tickets
so he says well if it's not in their
system
come back tomorrow
we'll find out because if you report it
stolen now if we don't know if it's
community people took it it's going to
be harder to get it out
do that i do a live sandman these
[ __ ] leeches i hate y'all still my
you know i'll go on live at seven
o'clock and i'll talk about it i'm on
the live talking about this rv
and a dude's trying to tap into the live
and he's like dude i think i'm looking
at your rv right now really no [ __ ]
and i'm like i'm thinking alright he
might be a troll that and a couple of
other people like yo man man that's in
your live right now is saying
he's dming you his number he thinks he
he's found your [ __ ] rv
so i go in the live with him
and sure enough he's like yo it's around
the corner from my shop he's walking up
there they busted the back windows the
slides were out
there was a spare key in there they
drove it to a whole nother part of town
they [ __ ] up the entire side of it
smashed the window
rifled through the hole inside but they
never closed the side the slides
and they were driving the sides out they
were driving with the sides out and just
dumped it and so um this dude he dm'd me
his number um and i in his address and i
drove up there so literally one of the
solutionaries on the live found my rv
solutionaries are better than cops there
you go yo
legit and so um
it's gonna be like i mean we got
insurance but it's gonna be like
and sure it's like everybody's like you
got insurance so it's cool i'm glad it
covers everything i'm like nah
people go like there's a girl oh you
have insurance no problem again you have
house insurance just light your house on
fire and see if they're gonna come back
with the three
says the problem with the libertarian
party is the rossboro problem they will
be used and sponsored by the left to
destroy the right via division been
there seen that never again yeah sorry
dude but that it's like now we got a
whole new group of people who are a lot
more savvy than that and that's what i
was telling you about before where we're
going to be like what we're going to be
doing is is pulling the right to be
better on the issues they're supposed to
be good on and destroying the
the neocon rhino whatever you want to
call them did you see the tweet from the
guy who said liz cheney should run as a
libertarian to take votes from trump liz
cheney if you're listening yeah please
please i am i'm not even kidding i'm on
my knees begging you enter my party and
try
try to take this from me liz cheney
please get up on stage in front of my
people and see what happens to you
when i see what happens when you have to
debate me liz cheney somebody tweeted
that in response to like some tweet
about liz cheney losing and then they
were like she should run as a
libertarian take those votes from trump
and i was like she's the antithesis of
you they have no idea listen you have no
idea what's up and and by the way the
the idea that raw look ross perot did
cost the republican the election i guess
you could argue but who did he cost
george herbert walker bush
that's who you're trying to preserve
like that would have been any better in
our country would be in any better shape
no look you know who the libertarians
won't be able to steal the election from
a republican who's good on liberty right
so get better on liberty and then you'll
be and then you'll be insulated again
this is a big one
i need to stop watching youtube says
7-eleven was a part-time job
[Laughter]
that's a great
great i love that oh man that's really
good that's a good one
troy dunham says dave ever since you
asked what would my presidential
campaign slogan be uh on potp your
comment section posts quote we need to
roll back the state what do you think
would look great on hats and t-shirts
i'll consider it
we need to roll back the state
seth hauser says ranked choice voting
will always give democrats the win but
how does that make sense uh wait i don't
get how he says that yeah so so here's
what happens i'd have to hear that
explain to me in alaska they have ranked
choice sarah palin runs there's a
republican and a democrat ranked choice
happens 60 of the vote was republican
but the democrat won the special
election oh okay so but that just
because
just as easily could go the other way no
yes i think the issue though is the risk
is that republicans are less likely to
understand a new system was put in place
democrats are are great at organizing
yeah so they're going to make sure all
of their voters know to vote you've got
to do first choice second choice third
choice
a lot of republicans probably just went
one and done
and then when their person didn't win
they got nuked and the democrat ended up
winning okay so that that is an
interesting argument i think there's no
question that democrats by the nature of
being democrats are always going to be
more you know kind of aware of the
democratic process so there is an
interesting argument to that i've never
really considered that before so fair
i'll have to think about that chaser 90
ek says this week my family bar closed
it opened in 1926 and we thought we'd
celebrate a hundred years but sadly
mcgee hands in northeast philly couldn't
survive the coveted policies and spike
in crime thanks mayor kenny and d.a
krasner ah man that that breaks my heart
to hear yeah it's horrible i'll tell you
i know um like i'm from new york city
born and raised and uh there are spots
that i know
you know like a lot of huge percentage
of businesses closed and didn't make it
through the lockdowns and i know these
ones there's like a few that just like
there was this uh this chinese
restaurant that was like a family-owned
chinese restaurant for i think they must
have been at least 20 30 years old and
they were on the corner of 78th and
broadway which is across from stand-up
new york comedy club which is where i
started doing stand-up comedy and they
were like the spot that i used to go to
like all the comics used to go to after
the comedy shows and then i lived around
the corner from them for years and we
used to go there all the time and they
closed and there's there's just one that
i'm bringing up but it's just yeah it's
heartbreaking man that whole family
business just destroyed over these
insane i think it's important for people
to remember this though like because
this is okay it may not be covet right
the next go-around it may be
behind the tracks climate change
whatever it is right i think it's
important for people to remember that
and go no [ __ ] you because we gave you
the two weeks to [ __ ] slow to spread
and it turned into [ __ ] our business
100 year damn near business
not being here anymore you know what i
mean so i think that part's very
important infinite will says if the
libertarian party runs on abolishing the
irs i'll vote for you that would be the
best way of scaling back the federal
government anyway um i mean we day one
yes abolish the irs executive order
right what created the irs was it
legislative legislation uh yeah well
the income tax was through a
constitutional amendment um but i i'd
have to think about the actual the the
internal revenues service but
the question is what what authority does
the president have and what can they do
well well but look i mean that's i don't
even think that's really the important
question because it's not as if like
look if you're going down the
hypothetical in your mind where the
libertarian candidate whoever that may
be
wins the presidency then the only thing
that's happened in that scenario is not
that the libertarian candidate won the
presidency there's been a major shift in
the way tens of millions of americans
are thinking about this and so your
guess is that it's not just that one
thing that happened but so you'd need
this mass movement being opposed to it
but absolutely i mean the irs is just a
disgusting like you know all the the
stuff you talk about with china like
your worst fear of china let's say we
lived in a free society and your worst
fear of china invading and taking over
the country would be that they would
install the internal revenue service
right like that'd be your worst
nightmare that they'd come in and
institute this organization which uh
dictates that it's a crime to be uh to
work it's a crime to produce and the
punishment will be a fee and you'll have
no fifth amendment protection you have
to incriminate yourself and we'll throw
you in jail if you don't pay your i got
a better idea i got a better idea
abolish the irs tomorrow the first thing
is that you should do is that all of all
of these irs field agents they got to
talk like this and they got to show up
with leather jackets and pro bars
and they have to they have to insist
that they're asking for protection money
that is not bad maybe help people
understand kind of what's going down
the state is the mafia masquerading as a
human rights organization it looks like
it was abe lincoln in 1862 he spun up uh
the commission oh yeah well that was the
first well that was the first income tax
uh but then it went away after the the
civil war that's right so lincoln
instituted an income tax during the uh
the civil war uh and then it went away
and then it was woodrow wilson in uh
1914 i want to say
uh where when it came back oh it was
1894 the supreme court declared the
income tax of 1894 unconstitutional yes
wow and then uh am i right 1914 i
believe is when it came back dick
horrible would would you agree woodrow
wilson dick
woodrow wilson is uh the worst president
in the history of the united states wow
even worse than joe biden yes yes far
worse far worse i mean as of so far i
mean joe biden is very bad but woodrow
wilson gave us the federal reserve the
irs
and world war one which as i said before
led to the rise of the nazis and the
commies he ruined everything really the
treaty of versailles really did yes the
nazi party oh no question yeah and and
also and the mix of the treaty of
versailles and the federal reserve which
created the boom and then the bust
leading to the great depression which is
what called in all the german loans and
destroyed the german economy i mean it
was all woodrow wilson ruined the 20th
century all right we'll grab just one
more here or maybe maybe one or two more
generally irritable says just hosted an
event on public safety and saw a black
guns matter shirt dave help a fellow
libertarian out uh
help a fellow libertarian on the
campaign trail vermont candidate
reddickforcongress.com tell james
lindsay i said hi
james lindsay i've i don't know james
lindsay but uh
with him a few times on twitter when he
was on there all right ladies and
gentlemen if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.com become a member and also
before you go
in the description below we got to link
tom mcdonald's song riot
we're big fans we're supporting him we
want to see him hit the charts and we
want to see the music that he produces
the ideas that he brings and the
influence he has start resonating more
in the cultural spaces of course we'll
be putting out new music in the next
couple weeks like we did with the last
song for the time being we don't have
one we're gonna shout out tom mcdonald
he's currently trending number two so
give him your love with his new song
riot you can follow the show at tim cast
irl you can follow me at tim cast you
want to shout anything out maj um be
kind to each other go
look into the libertarian party you
should really really really look into it
especially if you live in any urban city
in america you absolutely should be
looking into it um the work man support
the classes uh you know gibsongo.com
forward slash solutionary help us like
repair this damn rv man like and like
put these classes together these the
center that we have in philadelphia is
really in essence basically it's a big
classroom space um we're doing classes
on like trade skills i mean obviously
we're not doing welding in the building
but you know like trades and stuff like
that um conflict resolution firearms
training and stuff like that and all of
the classes are completely free to all
based on voluntary donations so
gibsongo.com forward solution hell yeah
well thank you guys so much for having
me and thanks for having both me and
maja on this one i was hyped to do this
uh with both of us uh
uh comicdavesmith.com the website comic
dave smith on twitter uh yeah that's all
michael malus for press secretary
we're there happening now uh ian cross
lenny and crossland.net catch me on
socials love you guys thank you for
coming see you guys later thank you guys
very much for tuning in on your friday
nights with us thank you for chilling
with us for sure thank you david mosh
for coming you guys can follow me on
twitter reminds.com at sourpatchlitz as
well as sourpatchlist.me
we will see you all next week monday but
also check out cast castle on other
shows at timcast.com and we'll see you
all next time
you